première précision tout de suite je vous
propose d'écouter les premières
réactions de nicolas sarkozy c'était il
ya quelques instants
la police française vient d'arrêter yvan
colonna la fin
la force est restée à la loi
à la loi de la république
oui ya vraiment quelque chose qui ait
changé dans notre république c'est que
maintenant nous faisons ce que nous
disons et vous me permettez de vous dire
quelque chose je pense à cet instant une
personne plus exactement à trois
personnes à madame erignac qui a tant
souffert à son fils et à sa fille et
cette arrestation je peux alors dédiée
aujourd'hui
maintenant ils vont pouvoir commencer le
deuil de ce grand homme qui a été le
préfet erignac voilà la conception de
l'état drac et la nôtre